patricia martin il n'y a pas que les
prix littéraires dans la vie aussi ceux
qui sont sur les prix sur la liste des
prix qui ne les ont pas mais mais qui
les auront un jour comme d'arcade à
zilina tank est pas là il ya
effectivement un gène de la sas alors il
faut dire qu'elle a le temps aux milices
parce qu'elle est très jeune vous avez
25 ans ce n'est pas indiscret de dire
votre âge allez vous et vous écrivez
comme on respire c'est à dire que ça en
fait c'est le premier roman que vous
publiez mais vous en avez écrit
paraît-il 11 autres avant et vous êtes
entré en ce moment-même décrire le 16e
c'est à dire qu'entre la publication de
celui là et maintenant il y en a quatre
autres co qui ont été mis en route alors
c'est l'histoire très très vite d'un
prix nobel de littérature un vieux
monsieur qui à 83 ans s'amusent à 83,56
pâtit je prie je t'appelle prétexte
attaques d'andy tâche on dit comme on
veut ou saas écrite et ach il est
effectivement assez antipathique il
convoque puisqu'il sait qu'il va mourir
un certain nombre de journalistes auprès
de lui quatre hommes qu'il va user et
puis une femme qui tiendra le coup alors
effectivement il est odieux c'est un
sédentaire adipeux dites-vous il a
quatre menton des yeux de cochon années
comme une patate une nuque lycée de
bourrelets et déjoue qui pendent bref
c'est un tas de saindoux et vous dites
aussi vous avez pensé à orson welles
penser le personnel est ce que vous
pensez que c'est sympa pour or ce noël
oui je ne sais pas exactement la bay
street la description d'orson welles
mais c'était plutôt le côté gros
monstres sacrés qu'était orson welles et
la fin de sa vie que je visais par là
mais non je pensais pas reproduire trait
pour trait une description orson welles
le gros monstre qui fait absolument ski
ski oui oui qui reçoit les gens d'une
façon d'amasser mal élevés oui et dont
même les grossièretés et les boutades
sont prises par les autres comme des
marques de génie
par les autres c'est-à-dire par les
journalistes oui que vous égratignez
quand même au passage assez joliment
william white les écrivains c'est
bizarre parce que à la fin il ya le prix
nobel puis à ces deux journalistes de la
fin on va pas raconter mais la fin est
vraiment super qui lui tient tête et on
a l'impression qu'elle s'est quand même
plus s'identifier à la journaliste cal
écrivain prix d'un bel ni à lune ni à
l'autre les gays l'écrivain c'est moi
même si je suis pas encore prix nobel
même si ça risque pas de m'arriver avec
un bouquin par web agence panneaux
thermiques du quotidien je voulais
continuer mais je vous dis pas la fin
mais je situerais la recherche d'un
journaliste qui puisse se livrer à ce
genre de tour de force avec eux je vous
rassure pour le prix nobel de
littérature il faut publier un certain
nombre de livres on n'a pas en général
le nouvel éditeur pour un livre je sais
mais enfin je crois que celui-ci
compromet les chances dès le départ
alors vous êtes ac est aussi le lecteur
qui en l'occurrence est un journaliste
parce que vous parlez des lecteurs
grenouille qui traverse vous les livre
sans prendre une goutte d'eau vous
pensez qu'on lit mal en général je pense
qu'il ya très peu de vrais lecteurs
c'est surtout un bouquin sur les
lecteurs sont les principaux personnages
du livre est justement ce qui donne à
cette journaliste pouvoir tellement
redoutable ça qu'elle est une vraie
actrice mais elle est bien la seule du
livre et je pense oui effectivement que
rares sont les gens qui sont capables de
lire
au point de vue de trouver les choses
par la forme de votre livre est
particulière puisqu'elle est quasiment
exclusivement dialoguées comme si
l'interview était une nouvelle forme de
mise à la question à la torture
deschamps vous avez l'impression par
exemple là dans l'interview qu'elle nous
nous livrons d'une sorte de torture
telle que vous la définissez dans votre
livre certainement mais enfin on est là
pour ça alors je m'y attendais mais là
c'est d'autant plus que c'est à dire
très longtemps ce sont de longs
ici heureusement ça ne va pas durer très
longtemps donc on va on va s'épargner
mais là les les interviews sont longues
donc forcément même s'ils sont pas liés
et ils ne le sont pas
le ton dégénère très vite mais je
commence on continue cette interview
hors antenne jusqu'à ce que la v2 fed
patricia martin on parle un petit peu
des autres prix des prix qui ont été
décernés aujourd'hui alors très très
rapidement les racines on a eu pas mal
du tout alors il ya eu le femina
étranger qui a été décerné à julian
barnes qui était notre invité la semaine
dernière l'humain en course on love etc
paru chez denoël il ya le médicis
étranger qui est paru chez grasset c'est
louis begley qu'il a eu c'est un
américain d'origine polonaise qui a
écrit un livre qui s'appelle une
éducation polonais c'est là aussi un
retour aux sources et qui a pas été
facile puisque il était petit garçon en
pologne au moment de la guerre je vous
passe les détails et puis il ya luc
ferry qu aussi était notre invité qui
lui a obtenu le médicis essais dont pour
le nouvel ordre écologique chez grasset
et alors là je voudrais m'attarder quand
même un tout petit peu plus sur le sur
le médicis et michèle riot qu'il a eu
avec ta culio alors c'est d'abord je
trouve que le médicis convient très bien
à quelqu'un comme michèle alliot parce
que vous savez que le médicis doit
couronner un ton et un style nouveau et
c'est vrai que c'est le cas chez lui
alors ta couillaud c'est un un roman on
peut dire davanture où on retrouve des
thèmes chers à rio notamment la mer
alors la mer aussi bien en tant que
paysage et que phone mais aussi la mer
en ce sens qu'elle vous oblige à vous
éloigner des autres des bruits inutiles
un peu de la civilisation et avoua vous
recentrer sur vous même et c'est je
crois aussi un trait de caractère propre
à michèle riot que nous avions invité au
sac de minus sont pas venus qui n'est
pas venu parce que tout simplement mais
ils aiment pas ils aiment pas là faut il
préfère les les tête à tête alors il
faut pas chercher dans ce livre là la
quotidienneté et le réalisme parce que
je crois que you were de ça ils ne
s'intéressent qu'aux exception et dans
ses romans il ya toujours des situations
d'exception et je vais vous en donner
une preuve absolument flagrante c'est
que les femmes dans ses livres sont
toujours très belle très intelligente
souvent plus que les hommes donc
supérieure aux héros merde dans la vie
quoi ce qui fait comme dans la vie non
pas du tout justement est ce qui fait
que ça l'est ce qui fait que ça les
isole un peu bon que dire d'autre en
fait que l'histoire je vais pas vous la
raconter je la laisse découvrir c'est un
prétexte à plein de réflexions sur l'art
en général sur la littérature en
particulier est ce dieu qui a fait
l'écrivain ou est ce le contraire se
demande rio et je finirai en vous citant
une phrase essentielle du livre ou rio
dit ainsi la littérature on était le
plus une tentative d'élucidation de
l'effroi qui l'a fait naître mais une
revendication-clé yards de sa propre
existence c'est à dire que la
littérature et l'art en général c'est
une réponse finalement à une question
d'angoise initial c une sorte de
nécessité primitive et qu'à partir du
moment où on perd ça de vue eh bien il
n'y a plus de littérature il n'y a plus
d'armes
[Musique]